et on est sur les dernières secondes de
ce tournoi évoqua quitte un 2e essai
terre me mais ils sont les vainqueurs du
et les mixed game challenge évoqua est
dit qu remporté le premier tournoi en
ligne des mureaux la ville proposait
cinq heures de compétition autour du jeu
rouquette league
c'est comme un match de foot mais avec
des voitures donc les voitures doivent
mettre le ballon dans dans les buts
voilà et donc ça se joue en équipe de
deux ou de trois donc là on a décidé de
le faire en équipe de deux parce que
c'est vrai que trois c'est plus
difficile pour les pour les jeunes de
trouver trois coéquipiers il s'agit d'un
jeu qui est multiplateforme et gratuit
donc tous les joueurs peuvent participer
donc si une personne à un pc ou l'autre
une xbox ils peuvent se rencontrer donc
participer au tournoi des matchs de cinq
minutes en élimination directe pour les
32 équipes inscrites pour ce challenge
la ville souhaitait garder du lien avec
ses habitants en cette période de co
vide
avant on faisait des tournois ea sports
on ad on a un parc de consoles donc on
faisait des tournois esport dans des
salles et l'idée c'était de pouvoir
continuer cette activité mais chacun
chez soi pour que voilà il n'y a pas de
risque de transmission donc chacun peut
rester chez soi de nombreux lots ont été
partagés entre les participants les
vainqueurs vont recevoir des casque
gaming la ville envisage de proposer
d'autres tournois il se porte